hello everyone welcome to my talk
well architecting and building a data
leak on TCP with open source tools my
name is Rafael I'm a cloud data engineer
at Google professional services we help
our most strategic customers migrate
into GCP and take most advantage of GCPs
I work with many of our customers across
many industries from marketing retail
technology to financial services so
Hadoop data leaks today are the most
common ones that is on-prem so most of
our impress customer or moving ado to
GCP and the trend is accelerating so
today I'll walk you through how to
architect them build a links on JCP and
what principles tools and patterns that
you should choose to build data leaks on
top of that it is important to know how
to secure and govern as they like so why
shouldn't they leaks on TCP so there are
many challenges that gain value out of
the on-premise data leaks today the
total cost of ownership is a very high
higher than they expected there are many
hidden cost it's hard to project is hard
to scale although Hadoop is also build
on the principle of scale governance and
security usually is an afterthought and
management burdens high on the team's
the admin teams are struggling with many
tasks such as turning or scaling or
resource allocation guiding the
application teams etc etc that this goes
on so by moving data links to cloud you
can extend existing investments in
on-premise environment the cluster size
is almost fixed tuned for maximum
capacity in cloud you have the chance to
optimize for the cost by spinning up and
down clusters and configure them
separately so also in the cloud you can
scale easily no more take months to get
the capacity you need by moving some of
the work to manage components it can
help reduce workload for your Big Data
team and let users focus on add more
values more directly by utilizing more
integrative tools and existing patterns
enable democratization and elect more
teams to get access the data they need
and finally by running more
work gloves on natively build tools and
platform your team can develop things
quicker and requires less maintenance
and more connectives through the GCP
platform so let's talk about how to
design and migrating data links to GCP
because we're talking about mostly
Hadoop data leaks for an on-prem
customer that's for what we most guide
our customer support there are many
tools to choose from to build a like for
example these are just an onyx product
and the GCP I will walk you through how
to choose and build they only be using
these tools and and also the tools of
your choice of course our guiding
principles here are open integrated and
safe so open to many open source big
data tools and file formats out of the
box avoiding logins and creating another
silo we want to make sure that data
leaks more connected with other tools
and capacities such as Apache spark
hypertensive fluid various GCP ml a IA
PS etc etc the third is safe safe to
migrate without having to make risky
decisions while getting benefit from the
cloud a couple of considerations when
you migrating stuff will be plenty so be
clear about your near-term and long-term
goals and priorities for example if your
data center release is ending in two
months
your goal should probably get your data
center or get your clusters out of there
as soon as possible rather than making
significant architecture changes along
with the best way to utilize GCP is to
choose the right tool for the workload
instead of finding just the replacement
tool for every tool you have today it is
best to utilize GCS a separate storage
and compute this will enable you to use
more ephemeral class or an other type of
cloud storage pattern to lower cost
improve performance and scale better the
last is needed rethink about your
operations you will use a bunch of
different types of clustering services
the old on-premise management tools such
as Apache and barrages wouldn't help
exactly this you want to make your
infrastructure and application approved
moments as code so your application
teams can deploy them because they know
it better
most of them customer choose to use
Apache airflow or a cloud composer to
rent their platforms airflow package is
most of the operations that you need to
interact with cloud providers products
into different air flow operators too
many clustered creation and deletion
could result in higher overhead for
example just jobs could take a little
bit longer to get to start and then shut
it down
so pulling the cluster together and let
a middle layer to choose a less utilized
cluster is a good idea
there are some tools out there for
example Spotify creates an open-source
pool called spydra this available on
github
so let's take a look at the usual
workload patterns we generally have
these four types of workload it is best
to know what type of workloads are you
running so these profiles and patterns
will help you choose which GCP tool to
use and what type of cluster to run and
how you should implement security and
data governance that this part is very
important so I like to discuss
technology choices into these five
different layers of a data leak so let's
start with the storage the main storage
for data Lake is the Google Cloud
storage it has many features listed over
here but most important ones are it has
immediate consistency when files an
object has read into GCS is mail
immediately available for listing so
this part is it very very important for
many Hadoop and spark were close
it helps facilitate many transient that
your ephemeral clusters by separate the
storage and compute there's no need for
three types replication such as in the
HDFS and you only need to pay for what
you use more a little bit more on GCS
connector it's designed to support
Hadoop ecosystem workload and working
with GCS
it's transparent to users a application
so you can use whatever format that you
have it has improved to support for Park
a file format for analytic workloads we
can simulate atomic directory operations
using cooperative locking so there's a
little bit more technical details in the
block here below so the best practices
for running the storage so small files
has some problem for HDFS it creates a
pressure for named those but for GCS too
many like small files will resolve like
too many round trips through the network
so that adds up latency always use the
new version of connectors to take
advantage of the new improvements we're
making them constantly
align your parkade file block size to
megabots because that's what the GCS
blocks
the boss to always partition your data
to gain filtering benefits and regarding
the migration the CRC check sum are
calculated differently for HDFS and GCS
for the same object so we apply some
changes to that to help you establish
checksums in order to use those so make
sure to use Hadoop versions as newer
than 2.9 if you don't have the ability
to upgrade cluster to a newer version
you can choose a workaround which uses
md5 checksum to move to at the end of
process through HDFS first then move
those files to GCS regarding the
migration tools DCP is the easiest way
to move data into GCS if you have h base
or Cassandra on your cluster you can
consider move them to cloud BigTable
BigTable is a managed service they
provide you manage replication is really
easy to scale up it's fully compatible
with HBase API
it has a nice data flow templates to
help YouTube uploading ones one of the
exceptions if you're using Apache
Phoenix the data model it's actually
similar to a class better than cloud big
table so you can consider move your data
there if you want to use a manage tool
for it if you only use Hadoop for data
warehouse use cases and dealing with
only structured data were a little bit
more semi structured data you can
consider implements or data leaks using
bigquery plus bigquery storage I'm
bigger storage API really treats data
warehouse like the storage and allow you
to use bigquery alike a data warehouse
plus that they like so integrase of well
with many many tools in GCP and also
open source ecosystem such as apache
spark high tensorflow and many of the
cloud AI products so next part we'll
talk about the meta store
Minister is a service that stores
metadata about time tables like schema
and location and partitions in the
relational database it's actually the de
facto standard for many the sequel
engines on Hadoop and also the newer
trend of table formats such as Delta
Lake patchy iceberg and Apache hoodies
having a centralized hi minister with
data on GCS enable separate storage and
computes further you can use multiple
cluster operate on different high tables
and Matthias Lee we just announced the
Alpha of data prop meta store is
actually a managed high- store you can
refer to the talk about that so you can
also map your bigquery tables into a
hamburger store so you can use something
like this and use the spark bigquery
connector to read data from bigquery
next
it's about ingestion layer many people
were using make maybe a patchy flume
patchy scoop or third-party tools for
free ingesting data into GCP Google
actually offers the fully managed open
source tool called a data fusion is
based on the two of seed app it's a
fully managed code free data ingestion
service we're building and managing data
pipelines it has pretty deep GCP
integrations women with many types of
sources and sinks if we prefer to still
continue to use Apache flume and scoop
with together with dip up and it also
supports many of the third-party tools
like talent that are informatica next
promote processing later this is mostly
based on your team skills we have you
can choose from one of these two
processing frameworks so data prop is
the manage to Hadoop framework so it has
many of the open-source data processing
for more such as bard flink high pick
and etc etc
dataflow is a service framework
using Apache beam so it's a different
programming paradigm over there so the
best practice of choosing processing
framework when migrating make sure you
at least recompile your application
because you want to match the Java
version spark and Scala version to the
data prop image version that you have
for example data prop 1.5 uses Scala
2.12 version of spark so it's maybe
different than than the one you're using
so at least recompile your application
to validate that when you deploy the
application not data product auto
scaling is good when you don't know the
exact size of the cluster that you need
but if you do know the job that will
need more than X number of nodes right
to start with that don't just start with
an auto scaling from a 1 node cluster it
wasn't a very long time to get there
enhance flexibility modes allow you to
store shuffle data on HDFS a primer were
closed to avoid job failures and reach
stars when summer than those fail and
one cuz there use that e to be M's and
pre-emptive of VMs are great for drive
down the cost but for pre-emptive VMS
you're having a risk of job failure or
lose progress when the pre-emptive VMs
goes away you can then approach jobs API
provides authorization authentication
auditing for jobs so you can consider
using that for submitting jobs to
cluster next we can talk about the data
warehouse choice native GCP data
warehouse is big party but you can
always run open source query engine such
as hi presto and others on data prop
customer found the best value after
migrating data warehouse to bigquery we
implement self-service data warehouse
the query personal operation it is fully
managed with flexible resource
allocation and pricing model they
support multiple file formats they can
find and be able to query them and enjoy
into bigquery so when migrated database
to bigquery in many case we scope a
bigquery migration proof-of-concept even
if the first stage of migration is a
later shift just to demonstrate the
values the difference between the
existing data warehouse and bigquery may
sounds big at the beginning but for
processing and reporting of structure
data most of our customers found great
value after POC a rollout to more users
within two or three months sometimes
just in a matter of four to five weeks
so what makes the migration to bigquery
simple migration is not just you know my
greatest origin in the engine alone it
also is not done until upstream and
downstream pipeline components are
identified and also migrated so move to
bigquery is easy for most people because
the connector exists for very simple
usage such as spark and bigquery
connectors type a query storage handlers
for downstream consumptions bigquery
supports most the BI tools by a JDBC
ODBC for many bigquery just simpler and
better user experience will see how the
security and data governance in the next
few slides typically you need Kerberos
arranger to confidently secure data link
or data warehouse for big queries are
built in and integrate with I am already
cup of the best practices when migrating
big Horace the poor state and integer
range partitioning may supports
clustering multiple columns however this
is different than high so if your high
table is not partitioned by date or into
the range you want to wrap you want to
repartition and load the data to
bigquery normally you can perform this
anyway just to be sure
bigquery uses standard NZ sequel
there will be some minor differences for
for some of the functions but largely
it's compatible with most of the query
but like above you can also if your hive
uses complex partitioning strategy you
may need to change those queries as well
the last if you used to run high detail
advert large scale and you also like to
bigquery to do ETL you can it's better
to do that in the dedicated project or a
dedicated slot so allocated pool then
using you know the same project or the
same slot that serves ad hoc queries
just ensure a better user experience so
we have some custom want to you know
keep their data on-premise and another
cloud while also using GCP and they also
want to use one query engine and one
sets of a script to avoid lattes or just
create another silence right in this
case you can actually use presto for
this it's the easy to deploy press
though on data prod with the big credit
connectors it naturally the connectors
use the bigquery storage API to prevent
you know faster query results presto has
many command other connects through to
talk to your for example transactional
data warehouse your other enterprise
data warehouse even legacy Hadoop
clusters so next I want to touch on
security and data governance there are
many types of identities in GCP
you're familiar with identity that's
when you sign in
there are service accounts that
represents the application let's see how
that impacts security here in a simple
setup in this case each user has a
distinctive as a count and that person
has a cluster used his and her service
account these cluster have data inside
CCSD and they need acids too so from GCS
access log perspective only service
accounts access the GCS but you can look
it up who actually did it because the
users and service account has mapping
access control is only on bucket level
so you could use I conditional I am to
fine-tune that if you use jobs API you
could find out which user actually
submitted jobs through the login but
more on that later in this set up with
Kerberos we're using the shared cluster
we want to make sure user a is who they
are so the user of syndicated by
Kerberos so we can stop people from I'm
using the service that they don't have
access to in the background all the API
calls are made by a service account of
that cluster so data prop was Kerberos
we've setup KDC on the master rooms and
KDC uses one we trust the cross room
trust to Active Directory if user SSH to
the cluster they were user in Linux user
to interact with Hadoop services before
they do that they need a K in it
together Kerberos ticket so when when
they access the house side that data
processor is actually used on the
service account BI tools in this case if
you're not using bigquery they will need
a gain access to the hive or press the
port to be m2 you know all the data
access as human identity previously we
talked about from the access log
perspective it is a service account to
access the GCS we develop with shorts
token broker and we presented last year
in the cloud next it will translate
Kerberos principle to Google identity
and called TCP ApS using that so now you
can control GCS data for
user assets and the actress control is
still on the bucket level with the
condition I am possible if you want a
table level access control then you need
to use the Patric Ranger
so for authorization management on data
Lake
let's take a look at what capacity
capabilities are available in GCP on
file system level on premise HDFS uses
POSIX permissions can you use that on
for HDFS mgcp but the HDFS comes with
the data practice only for temporary
storage so it's more important to look
at GCS excellence control for now GCS
only has bucket level access control
like I said earlier conditional IMS are
available with prefix settings but the
purpose is not really just do
fine-grained access control to each
object level so there's a limited number
of conditions you can play on the sequel
engine side on premise we usually use a
Patrick Ranger for restricting a certain
user tables or columns on GCP you can
continue user injur if you want to
continue to use open source sequel
engines such as hive and presto et
cetera
if migrator enterprise data warehouse to
bigquery mccrory natively provide an
access control on data set level table
level column level and row level these
couple fields the later features are
available in beta right now another
level access control is service access
control for example which Hadoop user
Laurie or sorry
which protip service or UI that user can
access to this is typically done by
either Hugh or use Apache knocks on data
proc you can use a passion ask gateway
to do that so first let's take a look at
how data product ops at the Younger
solve this authorization problem to some
extent
while we user a nice tomato job logs
will show who actually submit the job
and GCS will still show mr. service
account access the data however external
BI application doesn't really speak jobs
API so they can only connect to the
unsecure connection to the to the
cluster so in a more complicated setup
with Ranger lets you see how Ranger
solves that granular access control so
Ranger can be started as a data proc
optional component to use in a large
production system you might want to
consider centralized Ranger series so
you can be deployed on GCE with a cloud
sequel as a back-end database Ranger
provides database table column level
access control for hive server to any
request that goes through hive server to
will be checked and authorized by Ranger
this rule applies to BI tools that
connect soon hi-hi also has plug-in with
presto so the same time if you had to
come back to this presto Ranger can also
absolve that Ranger does not sync
permission to cloud storage like it did
for HDFS to avoid this issue you can
have a cluster that only provides sequel
service with Ranger to secure access so
people don't circumvent that as
mentioned before Apache NOx can help
control service access such as allowing
denied access to yarn UI or Qur an would
be something else
as access control for cluster used by BI
tools instead of letting the AI tool to
connect to the ports of hi or press the
or something else
it passes user identity to the clusters
so Ranger can also apply user base
authentication authorization
even without Kerberos next we talk about
metadata management tasks to make things
work together with open source big data
tools there are some solutions here GCP
offers data catalog which can loss data
from bigquery pub/sub natively and also
has a set of connectivity important
catwalk data from high Mehta store and
other systems data fusion provides a
weight of standardized data processing
resonated with native tools provided
data lineage for open source component
Apache Atlas can provide those sort of
lineage from that Patrick Ellis and
their catalog those provides a way to
attack and search of data automatically
categorize data and mask them or crucial
to processing sensitive data so Google's
data loss prevention API and Apache
Ellis books provide a way to categorize
data and mash them with necessary so
more on patchy Alistair provides data
lineage classification access control
working together with Apache Ranger and
also discovered capabilities it worked
with most open source components
it also has integration with the
third-party tool like Calibra so here's
a way how you can quickly create a new
cluster to test out the Apache Atlas
without affecting other were close so
some of the best practice is when we
come to security and data governance
application has like predefined behavior
so these are usually informal badge or
streaming workloads they could be long
running or they could be scheduled these
are not ad hoc jobs so there's no really
human interaction in them so normally we
can trust them running and grant the
minimum permission to the service
account they're running so you know how
to trace back to them for dinner
warehouse
it is mostly ad-hoc queries for user for
a disused cases right most user will
just create you know send simple queries
through hive and Paulo others we rather
we recommend using bigquery to simplify
this but if you do need to run have you
know run open source data warehouse such
as high or press though you can just use
a ranger to secure them for a third type
which we call exploratory workloads
they're specialized may be a data
scientists use PI spark to profile
data and build model you can set up data
prop cluster with derivative notebooks
for personal clusters or a team clusters
provided you can control access of that
service account if that doesn't fit
right you will say you want to share the
cluster was a few more people that you
can use Kerberos together with open
source token broker so let's talk about
a little bit about hybrid and
multi-cloud scenarios because I hear
this more often these days if you really
think about it
hybrid scenarios are pretty common so
every data migration has a hybrid stage
where some of your data on jobs are
migrated someone not to a communist
scenario first you need to have very
good you know interconnect because you
need to move data or jobs through you
know post environment all the time
full dns resolution it's important if
you bi-directional communication is
needed and it's crucial for Kerberos to
work to and then use a very powerful
orchestration tool like Apache airflow
or composer to launch tasks in all these
different environments our customer
typically like to choose one to the
control of the environment and be able
to launch out to all the environments so
make sure you have a discovery service
that routes the workload to the correct
cluster based on the request if you
don't feel like making copies of data to
different environments some of the zero
copy solution like a Luxio could be good
fit for that okay so that concludes my
talk to recap we went through a
high-level migration principles of open
integrated and safe rules of migration
such as establish clear priorities time
line separating storage and compute and
rethink about operations then we dive
into the text at choice we talked about
so a choice of GCSE bigquery storage and
cloud big table infusion for ingestions
data proc and data flow for processing
later or data warehouse later we discuss
a choice of five Preston bigquery and
what impact to consider when moving them
to bigquery and how to solve federated
environment query challenge with data
proc and presto then we talk about how
to secure and govern data leaks we talk
about Kerberos authentication with
impact on data access and auditing how
to authorize data using Kerberos ranger
jobs API and Apache and NOx bigquery
actually does very good job with solving
those access control challenges so
definitely it's a preferred way of
running data warehouse on GCP last we
discuss Apache Alice and did a catalog
for data governance tasks so that's
pretty much it thanks for joining my
talk